hey david are democrats going to get
destroyed in 2022
as most new parties in the white house
do
during their first midterm election so
we have a lot of different things
we there's a lot of sort of uh
milestones
that will be part of the 2022 midterm
elections
first of all these will be the first
midterms
after the removal of donald trump in
many ways
donald trump was sort of a crossing of
the rubicon
it was a before and after that we will
all remember in american politics
and so now that trump has been removed
he's in the process of being removed
i believe that there is some uncertainty
as to what we would expect in the first
non-trump era midterms number two
2022 will be the first election with the
newly drawn districts of the 2020 census
number three it is true that the party
uh
out of the white house tends to do well
in their first
midterms but i actually do think that
the 2022 midterms could be midterms
where
the democratic party does well even
though it wouldn't really line up with
the historical trend so there's a couple
different things
going on here first of all if joe biden
gets a second coronavirus stimulus
passed
and starts getting us out of the
pandemic which will of course be helped
dramatically by vaccines that are
soon to be approved and we see cases and
deaths declining
significantly in the second half of 2021
and into 2022 and we really he see
what feels like a return to normal by
standard
uh measures the economy does well
unemployment continues
decreasing significantly gdp
recovers etc you could really see
democrats do very well in 2022
much like republicans did well uh in the
first midterms after 9 11 in 2002
bush had post 9 11 and did well in those
midterms
biden could be the post coveted
president and democrats could actually
do very well in 2022.
the other signal and this is so early i
mean we're
we're getting to the end of the year
we're speculating here but it's so early
to really be thinking about this
if we continue seeing this slight shift
among suburban voters from the
republican party
to the democratic party that could be a
big factor
again depending on what redistricting
looks like on the basis of this year
census
biden's 2022 suddenly doesn't look
nearly as bad or risky as many
first-term presidents
obama 2010 comes to mind obama 2010 was
a disaster you had the tea party
movement you had
yes some racism that was reflexively
coming out in 2010 uh you also have
in the senate democrats don't have as
many tough seats to defend in 2022
they will have to figure out the seat
held by mark kelly because that's up
again in 2022 i believe i hope i'm not
wrong about that
republicans will have to defend seats in
ohio
wisconsin florida those would be big
fights
and then you are going to have some
likely incumbent republican retirements
as well
could be pennsylvania could be north
carolina chuck grassley in
iowa could be a likely retirement he's
an old significantly older guy he could
be
close to 90 right by 2022.
so the senate map back in when was it
hold on
27 2018 i guess after the 2018 midterms
i've been saying
i see 2020 senate as very tough for
democrats
i see 2022 senate as more of an
opportunity for democrats if they can
just roughly hold or gain a little bit
in 2020.
um we may indeed be heading in in that
direction so
i think that there's a real chance that
democrats actually
do really well in 2022 too early to tell
we'll be following it
and uh that will be let's get past the
biden
inauguration let's start decreasing the
number of cases and deaths from the
virus let's really focus on that and
then
we will get to 2022 there will be time
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
coupon code available never mandatory
but available at your discretion
the coupon code fresh start all one word
all lower case
saves you gobs of money on a membership
we will see you then